the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
[Music]
club
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
executive director of the St Louis chess
club Tony
[Applause]
Rich hello everyone and welcome thank
you for joining us at the 2023 us
championship and 2023 US Women's
Championship closing ceremony before we
begin a big round of applause for all
the
competitors and I uh would be remiss if
I didn't give a few thank yous but
before I do that I want to tell you a
quick story I promise Rex it's fast uh
many of you probably don't know this but
Rex wasn't the founding president of the
St Louis chess club he was a board
member he was a a founding board member
of the club but the president of the St
Louis chess club when it was founded is
a guy named Bob Jacobs chess players may
know Bob um Bob's a life master
correspondence Grandmaster
correspondence world champion um lived
in California for a long time moved to
St Louis when he retired and in fact his
nephew uh Bill Smith is an art guy who
recks collect and Bill had a a nice uh
meeting with Rex one day and said you
should meet my Uncle Bob he plays chess
too
um you know maybe you guys could start a
chess club or something and that was 15
years ago that Rex met Bob and and Bob
and Rex came up with this idea of
starting a chess club and today is Bob's
95th birthday so happy birthday
Bob the US championships are important
um to St Louis but but to our chess
Community overall one of the things the
US championships does it's not just a
tournament this isn't um a private
tournament this isn't just something
where the players are coming to compete
for some money this is the US national
championship everyone who competes in
these events all 24 players represent
the very best talent that America can
produce some of the players were born
here some of them decided to make this
their home and all of them ultimately
are the very best of American chess once
again congratulations to all the
players
and then my big long list I'll keep very
short and sweet of all the other folks
that we have to thank uh of course Dr
Rex Dr Genie and Rex singfield um the
vision behind the St Louis chest club
and the guidance that we've had for the
past 15 years thank you very
much I'd also like to thank all of our
friends at us chess for awarding the
national championships to St Louis and
giving us the honor of hosting the
Championships and then all of the folks
who made the events possible
from Shannon and Emily and Nicole and
Matt and and Nick and Britney and
everybody over at the hall of fame and
Holden and Ryan and Caleb and Denisha
and Amon and everybody at the chess club
who makes it happen thank all of you for
for making these major events happen Uh
Kevin Dew and uh Randy singfield at
Silverback and Spectrum Studios do all
of the great video production work that
you see here the amazing commentary team
journalists
production um uh marketing folks Rebecca
uh Sabina foer I mean literally the list
goes on and on I'm the guy who gets to
stand up here and receive thanks from
the fans and Spectators for all of the
great stuff that happens but I play this
big of a role in it and really it is all
of these folks here in St Louis that
make these national championships so
special thank you to all of
you and without further Ado uh I
promised to introduce her this way at
the opening ceremony and forgot but I
won't this time so we have the Godfather
of Chess we also have the Godmother of
Chess Dr Jeanie
[Applause]
[Music]
singfield wasn't this a great
tournament yeah
I was talking to the youngest uh
Grandmaster here I was and he didn't win
but I pointed out that it's sort of hard
when you have five of the 10 top players
in the world in the in a country so he
could try another country and win
right so anyway my my uh my job always
is to introduce
Rex and just I thought i' go back a
little bit for you those of you have
been here a really long time and the fun
things we've done crazy stuff we've done
for the how many of you ended up coming
for the uh launch of the chess merit
badge anybody here come for that yeah
that was cool we brought it for those
who didn't come we brought an astronaut
who was playing chess in outer space so
we're having a lot of fun and we hope to
have a lot more fun we have great
players and this would not have be out
except I have a crazy
husband so the you remember the
joke is like he said he was going to
start a chess club how expensive could
it
be so my job is to introduce Rex as the
Godfather of American
[Applause]
[Music]
chess
thank you Tony what a wonderful job
thank you jeie what an extraordinary
Championship just congratulations to all
of the players it's truly amazing and a
little piece of trivia did you know that
eight of the 24 players just compet it
in this event live in St
Louis
and there is room for the rest of
you and did you know that the two
youngest players in both fields at the
ages of 14 both came in third pretty
well
[Applause]
done so America's chess future looks
pretty bright I would like to thank of
course first my favorite thankes that's
a new world word uh the best commentary
team in the world for their amazing and
entertaining daily broadcast please join
me in thanking Grand Masters Christian
churilla yaser sarahan and wgm Katerina
nemova thank you
all Randy my son whose birthday is today
so if any of you are looking to send
phone calls or make phone calls call him
uh um along with uh Leonard our dgt
specialist and uh all the people at
Spectrum Studios uh just did an amazing
job put the bre the best broadcast ever
now although the studios are off site we
look forward to the remodel of the
Clayton studios in early 2024 can never
miss an opportunity for spending
money now we couldn't do all this
without the amazing staff it goes to say
we couldn't have do any of this without
the amazing staff so Tony you and your
team did an amazing job and joy Bray the
world's greatest general manager did
once again an amazing
job this is the 15th Championship we've
hosted and they just continue to get
better the World Chess Hall of Fame
staff led by curator Shannon and Emily
were just amazing your team continues to
do an unbelievably amazing job at the
artistic side of the game I would also
like to acknowledge Courtney sof Rebecca
Buffington Brian Flowers and our PR
marketing and Communications team at the
club and the World Chess Hall of Fame
they all did a truly great job and
lastly in principle the St Louis chess
club is committed to hosting the 20 24
us and Women's Championship in St Louis
thank
[Applause]
you all right guys I gotta go plan
another championship see
it um so these these national
championships uh don't run themselves as
you've heard uh some of the folks that
make it possible include the Arbiters
for the event so if you guys will stand
uh Chief Arbiter for the US Championship
Frank Guadalupe Chief Arbiter for the US
Women's Championship Chris bird Deputy
Arbiter for both events Karen
penck it's funny I learned a lot from
Chris and Frank uh Karen and I are kind
of like same level coming up in the
Arbiter world of things um but yeah you
guys have all been great and it's funny
when Rex was mentioning Joy it just
reminded me of one other story it was
here on this stage uh probably 2010 I
want to say us Championship it would be
our second time hosting the event still
had no clue what I was doing but luckily
we had a great team Joy was literally
crouched down behind the table up here
handing me Awards as we're we're we're
handing them out to the players until at
some point I wanted to acknowledge joy
and say thank you to her for being such
a great boss and a great leader for the
team and she had to peek her head up
from behind the table back there and
wave to everybody it was great great
thanks
Joy okay so uh now we're on to the
important part of the evening and that's
the prize giving the awards uh for the
US Women's Championship and the US
Championship so FRX and Genie if you
guys could join me on the stage
please and the way this will work is
I'll call out third place second place
first place ask each of the the folks to
come up to the stage when your name is
called we'll pose for a picture with Rex
and jeie and then you can make your way
back down the winner from each section
if you'd like to say a few words uh
you're more than welcome to join us at
the mic too starting with the US Women's
Championship 14-year-old International
Master elect Alice
[Music]
[Applause]
Lee
[Music]
[Applause]
re you get to keep that
one in second place in the US Women's
Championship 2023 from St Louis us our
very own go beum Tokyo Nova
[Applause]
[Music]
be
and in first place your 2023 US Women's
Champion International Master Karissa
yip
[Music]
hi guys uh I'm Karissa thanks for
joining me this
evening uh I really don't like giving
speeches but here we are uh okay so
first I want to thank Rex and jeie for
their contributions to CH in America um
they've given so many opportunities and
you know one example that's very
important to me was the US junior girls
Championship so when I was you know
around 10 years old the US junior girls
is like a independently run and
organized
tournament and there was never like a
guarantee that it would happen any year
which you know kind of sucks because
such a great idea you know
10 best junior girls in the country
fighting it out um and so you know
there's like a little 10-year-old me I
never know if I'm G to get to play that
year or not uh and in 2017 the
tournament came to the club and it's
been there since then it was such a
staple I feel like a you know American
chess summer got the junior
championships senior
championships um and I just think it's
really important for young players
especially young girls to have this
opportunity to compete against each
other at the highest level um and you
know I've played a ton of Junior
Championships now over the years and of
course a ton of US championships um but
10-year-old me could never really
imagine this sort of thing would happen
so my sincerest thank
you uh I also want to thank the club and
you know everyone who's worked super
hard to make this such an amazing
experience so the staff Arbiters
production team photographers commentary
even though I know none of you guys bet
on me um we'll be having words about
that later but you know best commentary
team in the world I my dad and I always
like rewatched every round so
fun uh onto the actual
tournament there's just so much to say
it's such a roller coaster um shout out
to my opponents for being such fighting
competitors every round was was a
nailbiter and every game was a struggle
um special shout out to ban of course
who's one of my closest friends in the
tournament um and who also had an
amazing event and really pushed me to
bring my
aame uh thank you to my coaches for all
they've done for my chess um shout out
to my second for this event I can't
really name drop him in case someone
else steals him from me you know but he
PR me for every round helped me sort of
keep my head on straight after some
rough games and didn't give me just good
opening advice uh but good tourament and
emotional advice uh finally I want to
thank my friends and family my friends
for following the event for cheering me
on for being my rock and of course thank
you to my parents for being unwavering
in their love and support and for all
that they've done for my chess career uh
couldn't be up here without them my
dad's in the audience
today recording me I
guess
and a big shout out to him who has been
my you know biggest supporter since the
beginning he taught me how the piece is
moved he's been my first coach and he
still hopes me for my chest today so
thank you
Dad uh I'll stop soon so you know we can
all get to celebrating but first a quote
um and I don't really want to brag but I
just really want to quote ice spice for
you know such an icon today uh so in our
favorite rappers famous words people be
saying one hit wonder well what now to
hit
wonder thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you Carissa that was all too young for
me you're going to have to explain who
that guy is what that means I got
nothing right exactly
but chissa did say one thing that is
absolutely correct and that is that
Percy y has to be probably one of the
best chess parents I've met we've known
Percy now at the chess club for 14 years
or so something like that 13 years and
he's always been a great advocate for
his kid and at the same time being a
great supporter of the chess Community
good job
[Applause]
Percy okay on to the US Championship boy
what a field I mean this tournament just
keeps getting stronger and stronger
every year um and this year was no
exception um I I think Rex had did
mention during his remarks that uh a
14-year-old player did in fact tie for
second place in the uh us Championship
unfortunately the tie breaks didn't work
out so great for him so Abby Maya M
Mishra AB Mayu actually received fourth
place on tie breaks so our third place
finisher who will join us up on the
stage now also a St Louis resident is
Grandmaster lenia
Dominguez
[Music]
[Applause]
taking second place on tie breaks
Grandmaster Wesley
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
and despite the fact that he had like a
whole two block commute to get here to
the closing ceremony I would like to
introduce uh for the second year in a
row your reigning us chess champion
Fabiano
[Applause]
[Music]
Carana
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much uh it's such
an honor to be up here and uh I really
don't take it for granted at all to be
able to the privilege it is to be able
to play these events uh it's it's a
great privilege for a chess player and
it really is all thanks to uh Dr Genie
and Rex sinkfield for their generosity
over so many years and all they've done
for the chess Community for chess in St
Louis in the United States and and also
around the world and so I really want to
um to thank you both personally for
everything you've
[Applause]
done but of course it takes so many
people to run such an amazing uh
institution as the St Louis chess club
and the Chess Hall of Fame and everyone
does such an amazing job at the at the
chess club and also I I one of the
things about the Reconstruction of the
club recently is that we've had the
privilege to play in the Chess Hall of
Fame in the last few events and just
like walking through uh to get to the
the plane area and seeing all the
exhibits and um all the work that the
people do there is is also really
amazing um so it's it's actually been a
bit of an inspiration to to be able to
walk and see all the art and everything
before playing so thank you also to all
the people at the Chess Hall of Fame and
of course at the St Louis chess club
it's um
and of course to all the people
following the event um all the chess
fans all the enthusiasts it um yeah it's
it's really good to know that chess is
appreciated and loved and uh that chess
in the United States and of course also
in St Louis has has a really bright
future so thank you to
[Applause]
everyone
[Music]
that's crazy who would have thought when
I was a freshman at viani high school
just learning how the pawns move I'd
shake hands with Fabiano caruana pretty
cool
right the reason we do all of this is
because chess is important chess isn't
just a game chess teaches us all these
important life skills how to plan ahead
how to solve problems how to handle
defeat and how to handle Victory so
thank you to all of the players once
again for being great ambassadors for
the game and helping us continue to grow
uh the game of Kings now for all of you
now is the fun part we'll clear all the
chairs off of the dance floor here the
food will be open the bars will be open
make yourselves at home and have a great
time thanks again for joining us and we
hope to see you
[Applause]
[Music]
soon
w
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited